apple finally sent out their invites for
their september event and it looks like
it's definitely happening on the 14th at
10 a.m which is extremely exciting
because we've been waiting three months
for this tech drought to be over but
enough about that let's get into the
actual invitation that apple sent out
because there are a bunch of easter eggs
and hints within the infight itself and
other tweets like the one from apple's
greg joswiak that point to some of the
biggest rumored features and changes
actually getting revealed at the event
so with that said let's get right into
analyzing the best looking invitation
apple has ever created but first i want
to mention our new m1x chip t-shirt
design which you can find in our merch
shelf right below this video to start
things off let's dig right into the
title of the apple invite which is
california streaming now this is
obviously a spin on the california
dreaming song by the mamas and papas
which i admit is a pretty awesome song
because it takes us back to the rise of
apple in the 1970s when they released
the revolutionary apple ii computer and
that was also back when they had the
multi-colored apple logo that they used
in a bunch of their original and
creative ads but getting back to the
california streaming invitation apple is
using california because that's
obviously where their made headquarters
is based out of and the streaming part
of it likely points to the fact that
this event will continue to be streamed
online instead of being in person now
the next detail could be a bit of a
stretch but the streaming part could
also be pointing to better 5g support
with the new qualcomm x60 modem which is
rumored to be coming to the iphone 13
lineup and there's also a chance we
could be getting 5g support for the
first time on both the ipad mini 6 and
the apple watch series 7. now looking at
the image itself we can see a beautiful
glowing apple logo and one of the
details that i noticed is that the
inside of the apple logo looks a bit
different compared to the background
almost like there is some sort of a
filter applied to it now in my opinion
this is directly pointing to the leak
from mark german where he said that the
portrait photo mode is getting a more
advanced iteration of standard photo
filters so instead of applying a filter
to the entire image at once the iphone
13 will use artificial intelligence to
add filters to objects and people inside
of the photo and not the background and
this is exactly what apple is showing us
in the event invitation now going even
deeper the fact that the invitation
image is of a scene happening after
sunset kind of points to apple improving
nighttime photography with the iphone 13
lineup and this points us to a new leak
from pine leaks where they claim that
all camera sensors on the iphone 13
lineup will receive at least 15 percent
more light with the ultra wide camera
getting up to 40 more light this by
itself is gonna be huge for nighttime
photography because it's going to
greatly help both evening photos and
night mode photos as well by reducing
the overall noise and the amount of time
it takes to take a night mode photo now
on top of that ming chakra reported that
the iphone 13 pro models will feature an
improved ultra wide camera with
autofocus which will be required if they
make the aperture of the ultrawide lens
larger to allow 40 more light since
doing so lowers the depth of field or
the amount of a scene that can be in
focus at once now on top of all of that
greg joswiak tweeted out an augmented
reality version of the event invitation
and as you can see the camera points up
at the stars which basically confirms
the rumored astrophotography mode that
max weinbach leaked a while back and
adding on to that anger danger on mac
rumors forums notice that the stars are
moving or rotating in the sky which
further confirms the astrophotography
mode pine leaks also chimed in on this
new feature by mentioning that when you
use night mode it will automatically
detect when stars are in the frame and
adjust the scene for them so everything
is going to happen automatically instead
of having to manually select an
astrophotography mode i was also able to
figure out that reuben wu on twitter is
a photographer behind apple's event
invitation just by the amount of times
he retweeted all of the event tweets and
as it turns out he himself is an
astrophotographer
further confirming that the new mode is
coming on the iphone now on top of all
of that pine leaks mentioned that night
mode will get a new algorithm that
analyzes structures resharpens and
adjusts shadows in nighttime shots we're
also going to be getting better color
science for night mode shots which is a
huge deal since it'll no longer mess
with the white balance on your face now
going back to the invitation the 914
text within the ar version could also be
pointing to a new always on display
feature which has been leaked by max
weinbach many months ago and reiterated
by mark german so there's a chance we
could see that on the iphone 13 lineup
one thing i also noticed is that the
glowing edge of the apple logo almost
seems like it's related to lasers which
is likely pointing to a new 2nd gen face
id system which is going to help make
the notch smaller while improving
reliability and possibly speed as well
and there's a good chance we're going to
be getting a second gen lidar scanner on
the back of the iphone 13 pro as well
and this actually ties into a little
detail from greg joswiak's tweet where
he added a little portrait frame emoji
at the end of it which points to apple
improving the performance of portrait
mode photos which is something that max
weinbach leaked back in may claiming
that portrait photos will now use the
depth information from the lidar scanner
which it didn't do before and this
should greatly improve the blur edging
and avoid random mistakes now another
thing that ben bengeskin on twitter
noticed about greg's tweet is that
within the short clip you can notice a
little sunset in the corner of the frame
which could be pointing to a new bronze
or sunset gold iphone color option which
is something that is also rumored to be
coming with the iphone 13 lineup and
interestingly the twitter hash flag that
apple chose for the apple event hashtag
is basically a sunset at twilight
further pointing to the new color option
and now moving on to the final detail
that i found that gives us a hint at one
of the biggest features we should expect
on the iphone 13 pro
is the actual source image that apple
used for the invitation a twitter user
helped me find the source image by
accessing the website source code and it
looks like this an incredible landscape
scene of this beautiful tree line that
fades to black on the sides
interestingly the aspect ratio of this
image is reminiscent of the ultra
panavision 70 millimeter film aspect
ratio which classic films like ben hur
were filmed in as well as the quentin
taratino flick the hateful eight so as
you can tell this new invitation has me
extremely excited for the event next
week where we should expect a bunch of
new product reveals like the iphone 13
lineup the apple watch series 7 the
airpods 3 the ipad 9 and the ipad mini
6. now if you want to know every
specific detail about what to expect
from each of those products definitely
watch my full september event leaks
video after this one is over but right
now i want to finish off with a couple
of brand new leaks that just came out a
new mac slave charger for the iphone 13
just popped up in fcc filings ahead of
launch which could go hand in hand with
the rumors of apple using a larger
wireless charging coil for the iphone 13
lineup to allow for better heat
management moving on according to shrimp
alpha pro both of the iphone 13 pro
models will support low earth orbit
satellite connectivity in the united
states using elon musk's starlink
satellite internet system but for now
it'll likely only be used for emergency
calls and messages for areas where you
have no cellular signal pine leaks also
gave us some more details where they
don't expect a price hike for the iphone
13 lineup which is great news they also
believe that the optical image
stabilization system will be less
aggressive and more smooth compared to
previous models which will help with the
new portrait cinematic video mode which
they believe will use a new warp system
which will attempt to keep a subject
close to the center of the frame they
also claim that the airpods 3 charging
case will have a 20 larger battery
compared to the second gen and it's
gonna have wireless charging included
they also said the overall sound quality
will stay the same but will be getting
an improvement on the base and low end
frequencies the batteries on the airpods
3 earbuds themselves will be around the
same size as the current airpods pro
which is actually around 72 percent
larger than the battery cell in each
airpods 2 earbud which is a very good
sign for battery life and finally pine
leaks claim that the apple watch series
7 should give us our first real battery
life improvement since the original
apple watch and by the way mark german
claimed that the series 7 will be
available in limited quantities at
launch so if you want to get one
definitely pre-order it as soon as it
becomes available or you could end up
waiting weeks to get one so there you
guys have it hopefully you enjoyed my
analysis of the apple event invitation
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
watch the full september event leaks
video right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]